الى توتر الان في شبه جزيره الكوريه حيث
وقالت وزاره الدفاع اليابانيه ان كوريا
الشماليه اطلقت ثلاثه صواريخ بالستيه
متوسطه المدى صباح اليوم سقطت جميعها خارج
المياه الاقتصاديه لليابان رئيس الوزراء
اليابانيه قال ان بلاده ستواصل تعزيز
دفاعاتها ضد صواريخ كوريا الشماليه لحمايه
الارواح والممتلكات
وافدت وكاله الانباء اليابانيه بانه طوكيو
تطور صواريخ يتراوح مداها بين 2000 وثلاثه
الاف كيلو متر لنشرها العامه المقبل
كما قدمت طوكي واحتجاجا لدى سفاره كوريا
الشماليه في بيجين وطالبتها بوقف ما
وصفتها بخطواتها لاستفزازيات الخارجيه
اليابانيه قالت في بيان انه تم عقد
مشاورات مع واشنطن وصول بشان اطلاق
صاروخان اليوم
بشده اطلاقا كوريا الشماليه لعدد قياسين
من الصواريخ البالستيه هذا العام ووصفه
الحادثه بالتهديد الخطير والوشيكي للامن
الاقليمي كما انه يعد تحديا واضحا المجتمع
الدولي
الجنوبيه واليابان والولايات المتحده
مستمره في تعزيز تعاون الامني من اجل نزع
الاسلحه النوويه من كوريا الشماليه بشكل